- Fresh Prince asking "I
hear story telling a lot
nowadays" we talked about this at the top,
"What's one way I can
do that on social media,
on Instagram as an example?"
- I think it's a great
question Fresh Prince,
and there's a couple of things.
I think on social, yeah
Instagram is great,
awesome channel, go
where your audience is.
If that's the demographics
of your audience
and they're likely interested
in your idea or product
then that's absolutely where you go.
Or Facebook or maybe
more traditional channels
of Twitter, but I think
definitely it's fantastic,
so you could embrace that channel.
The other thing, you have
to have compelling content.
So on things like Instagram,
great visualization,
pictures, video and also
on social media as well,
the great thing about
social media is it's not
one shot, it's a continuous conversation.
It's a storyteller.
One of the most compelling
ways to tell your story
and I guess it's the way you start with,
is what problem am I
solving for my customer.
What is the pain point
that my customer is going
through everyday that
I'm going to alleviate?
What is the gain they're
going to get from it?
If you answer that question,
you're really clear
about what problem I'm
solving for my customer,
what is the pain point, and then you show
through stories, especially with pictures
and visualization, then I
think you're off to a winner.
Then, the great thing
with social is you can get
other people involved and
you can build a community
where you are one of the opinion leaders
on the conversation and
you're one of the participants
in terms of shaping the conversation
and that's so powerful.
The first thing is again,
you want to, if you
got the idea, you know
what you want to do,
you know what pain
point it solves, you got
a great idea in terms of
how to show your product
and you can show it
through demos, pictures,
videos all that sort of stuff.
Then, you'd get out
there and do it because
you'll find other people
out there who will be
really willing to contribute.
The great thing is, you
can get loads of almost
instant feedback, market
research, whatever
you want to call it, and it's all free.
It's all free, you just lap it up.
Evolve your product
according to the advice
you're getting from the
folks out in the community.
- I think for any kind
of story telling it's
understanding first,
what do you stand for,
what's your mission, what's your value.
For me, Believe, I want
to help entrepreneurs.
Everything that I create oozes Believe.
Every video I make, every interview I do.
Every picture that I post.
I think what you want to
do is create something
that you want to go and
show your grandkids.
You want to create something
that you're so proud of
that you want your
grandkids to see in every
post that you're creating.
With an Instagram structure,
Instagram typically
has been, you put your
best picture out there.
You curate all of these
pictures, you take 1000 pictures
and one of them, your best one is the one
you're going to put up.
But the recent change with
stories has been super
interesting and now you have
the ability to tell stories
along your day, just like snap chat does,
it disappears in 24 hours.
It's a chance to develop
the more human side
of what you're all about, what
you're routine looks like,
the behind the scenes,
talking to customers
and so, it's a great way,
I think that entrepreneurs
can win because that's how you beat bigger
players in your industry,
is the human connection.
It's the why, because
you care more about what
you're doing than some
other big corporation might
in your space and so going
all in on your story is
going to be really important and Instagram
is a great way to do it.
These quick, ten second
clips of what's happening
in your day, why you
started this thing and why
it's also great is you
don't need to have a big
budget, Stephen talked
about ti being free.
People don't expect, with
youtube, there's still
some expectations over video quality,
and a lot of players are
spending a lot of money
with production crews
and camera men and lights
and all that, and with an Instagram story
or SnapChat it's expected
to be real, it's expected
to be a little more
gritty because it's just
taken from your phone,
and so that's really
an awesome chance for you to practice
telling your story, sharing
what is so important
to you in your day to
day life and a chance
for your customers and
your audience and your
followers to understand
you better and connect
with what you're all about.
So I would highly recommend
that as a practice,
even just for you to
practice because you know
it's going away in 24 hours.
The thing only lives for
24 hours, those stories,
so developing the communication skill
to talk to an audience
is a really valuable
exercise to go through.